hello my name is Julian poo from the St
Louis chess club and today we're going
to talk about the world of Chess so
recently Magnus Carlson played Hans
Neiman in a title Tuesday game this is
the first time they've play played a
real game of chess since their
controversy that game um was sort of an
uneventful draw but maybe a sign that
there's um
reconciliation the game went e45 and we
got some burlin this is a rookie one
Berlin nothing too exciting really
happened here um there was this t played
later with uh Queen uh Queen takes E8
which just liquidates all the pieces and
black made a pretty comfortable draw but
um the game itself isn't uh isn't the
thing that's spectacular the thing
that's spectacular is these two players
are officially playing each other again